bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de
ville parce que même si on est 75 % de
français à y vivre
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas entre le 10e et le xiiie siècle les
urbains ne dépassait pas 15% de la
population et c'est justement à cette
période qu'on va s'intéresser clair bref
précis une introduction comme on les
aime je sens qu'on va encore totalement
ignoré ma période
réveillez moi si vous avez besoin de mon
expertise alors c'est parti
[Musique]
même si le territoire français actuel
s'urbanise durant l'antiquité romaine
je disais l'antiquité romaine vitesse
entre le cinquième et le xième siècle la
plupart des villes perdent de leur
surface
chartres passe de 200 à 11 hectares
reims de 6 ans à 60 hectares les villes
se retrouvent tout troué de partout avec
des vignes et des champs entre deux rues
et ont construit des maisons n'importe
où sans respecter les ruines antiques
bien droites et plans et pau damien
sanou passé un peu au-dessus bon
d'accord on retrouve le même schéma à
paris dont les habitants s'étaient
étendus durant base empire romain de
l'île de la cité vers la rive gauche
puis se retranche bien comme il faut
derrière les remparts de l'île de la
cité à partir d invasion par marc puis
des raids vikings de barbarie comme
benny b dj douter ce bel abbès d'autres
villes subissent en plus des épidémies
ce qui n'arrange pas les choses
durant toute cette période la population
seraient partis autour des villes ou des
abbayes selon un mode de vie rural
inspiré des germains mais à partir du
11e siècle ça repart et voilà adieu
l'antiquité la production agricole
augmente la france commence à développer
son commerce
et tout ça permet un nouveau
développement pour les villes souvent
grâce à l'intervention des seigneurs
locaux seigneur qui pouvaient être soit
laïque soit religieux certaines gilles
reprennent donc à partir des anciennes
villes romaines comme paris chartres
toulouse ou arles dont même
l'amphithéâtre est occupée mais d'autres
villes médiévales se forme autour d'
abbey comme conques ou autour de mode
castrale comme castelnau neuf châteaux
et ses pratiques parce qu'ils la mouche
château dans leurs noms ou encore de
grandes villes médiévales comme tour
arras montpellier était à la base
polynucléaires et se forme à partir de
la réunion progressive de tout ce qui se
trouve dans le coin châteaux abbayes et
c'est par exemple à paris au 14e siècle
80% de la surface de la ville est
possédé par des ecclésiastiques contre
10% par le roi et le reste par des
petits seigneurs lorsque la ville est
formé par beaucoup de monastères inclus
au fur et à mesure dans son territoire
dès le douzième treizième siècle et
ville reprennent leur taille antique et
continue de se développer grâce à
l'apparition d'artisanat de tavernes et
grâce à l'exode rural elle se dote de
cathédrale de quelques maisons en pierre
et d'enceintes pour protéger le tout la
démographie
exposé d'ailleurs parlant de la
population mais seul document qui nous
permette de dénombrer les habitants des
villes sont les documents fiscaux qui
apparaissent au début du xiv ème siècle
mais qui conte les feux et non les
personnes les feux c'est des foyers
c'est chaud comme il ya sûrement 4 à 5
personnes par feu ça nous permet de
constater que les petites villes comme
le mans ou annecy ont entre 2 et 3000
habitants les villes moyennes comme
marseille ont dix mille habitants et les
grandes villes comme lyon lille ou entre
20000 et 40000 habitants eh oui j'ai
retenu tous ces chiffres les plus
grandes villes d'europe se trouve dans
les flandres et en italie grâce à leurs
importants de production textile et la
grande exception et paris qui à 250000
habitants dès le 14e siècle
mais laissons de côté les chiffres
quelques instants pour parler un peu de
la vie en ville
un proverbe allemand du début du xvème
siècle dit que l'ère de la ville rend
libre à la différence de la campagne où
la population est généralement a servi
on pense que la ville permet plus de
liberté voire peut-être l'ascension
sociale
il existe donc un esprit de la ville les
gens sont fiers d'être urbain
les villes sont des espaces de culture
aussi puisque c'est là que la plupart
des fables et des fabliaux sont écrits
dans un fabliau du xiiie siècle on
trouve par exemple l'histoire d'un
paysan qui va à paris pour la première
fois et perd sa femme sur le petit pont
tellement il ya monde est tellement
yabon qui rentre dans son village avec
une autre femme
parce que pourquoi pas généralement les
citadins sont un peu mieux mis en valeur
dans les fabliaux que les paysans qui
sont décrits comme un peu idiot les
villes sont aussi un peu moins touchée
par les famines que les campagnes ce qui
en fait d'office des espaces d'abondance
et aussi de sécurité puisqu'elles sont
entourés par des murailles qui sont
fermées la nuit
une cloche annoncent leur ouverture le
matin à ce moment là entre les laitières
venu vendre leur lait
les rues accompagnés de nombreuses
autres crieur issus de la ville ou de la
campagne qui proposent du vin des
légumes etc
il existait des crieurs qui annonçait
l'ouverture des bains publics parce que
rares étaient ceux qui avaient de quoi
se laver chez eux
ah bon momo lavier en plus des crieurs
on peut entendre des cloches qui rythme
la journée le bruit des différents
artisans qui travaillent dans leur
boutique ou qu'ils sont venus installer
leurs tables pliantes là où il y avait
de la place
les montreurs d'ours ou de singes les
animaux de toutes sortes
les processions qui fait les différents
simple et mambo d'ordre mendiants qui
prêche sur les places et dans les
églises
et puis des événements un peu plus
exceptionnel comme les kermesses car
laval où les entrées royales les rues
des villes sont étroites
elles font 10 à 12 mètres au plus large
et sont rarement pavé au 14e siècle il
n'existait pas de différence entre les
quartiers on peut trouver un hôtel
particulier à côté de petites maisons
sont souvent construites en bois et
recouverte d'un enduit comme la plupart
des maisons n'ont pas de latrines
on trouve des latrines publiques un peu
partout qui ont laissé leur marque dans
la toponymie par exemple il existe une
ruelle du pipi à châlons sur marne
je pense que ses habitants peuvent être
fiers de cet héritage les plus riches
ont quand même des latrines chez eux qui
se déverse ensuite dans la rue grâce à
des conduits et s'écoulent par le
caniveau central dans lequel on évite de
marché d'ailleurs si les russes sont un
peu trop rempli on s'emmerde
littéralement je pensais pas aborder un
tel sujet un jour et puis quand vient le
soir les bougies sont interdites ce à
cause des risques 20110 alors une cloche
annonce la fermeture des portes de la
ville et tout le monde va se coucher
bien sûr le développement des jeunes
nécessite un peu d'organisation
au début les villes sont sous la
juridiction du seigneur qui possède les
terres qu'ils soient religieux ou laïcs
mais dès le douzième siècle elles
commencent à réclamer un petit peu plus
d'autonomie et obtiennent des documents
qui la leur accorde le but de cette
autonomie est aussi de se débarrasser de
toutes les taxes imposées par le
seigneur qui gêne le développement
économique de la ville
ces documents sont appelés des charges
communales ou bien charte de franchise
au nord ou charte consulaire au sud
j'ai connu un consul cette charte
concerne les bourgeois c'est à dire ceux
qui ont ce statut parce qu'ils vivent en
ville depuis plus d'un an
ou parce qu'ils ont une maison en ville
ça peut varier parmi eux aient choisi un
groupe de personnes nommées échevins au
nord ou consume au capitole au sud qui
dirige la ville
ils ont le pouvoir de rendre la justice
d'établir des impôts de lever des
et c'est la plus vieille charte est
signée au mans en 1070 est la plus
vieille conserver date 2112 concerne la
ville de lorie ou loris on va dire loris
sinon on a l'impression que c'est la
ville de la chanteuse l'autonomie des
villes est une question qui fâche un peu
en 1112 l'évêque gondry qui était senior
de la ville de laon est assassiné parce
qu'il avait refusé d'accorder une charte
communale aux bourgeois de la ville
de manière générale l'existante
davantage de résister à cette
émancipation des villes que les seniors
laïcs dans les chartes on retrouve aussi
certaines mesures telles que
l'affranchissement d'un cerf qui aurait
passé un an dans la ville sans être
réclamés par son seigneur comme quoi à
l'air de la ville rend parfois vraiment
libre les conseils d'échevin ou de
consul forme donc petit à petit des
véritables conseils municipaux dirigée
par un maire qui est souvent un élu pour
un an
ils sont choisis parmi les notables de
la ville des marchands ont des juristes
par exemple ce qui en fait un système
plutôt oligarchique quand ce sont les
huiles qui dirige les séances peuvent se
tenir dans des beffrois ou des hôtels de
ville ou parfois dans de simples maisons
quand on n'a pas d'autre endroit où se
réunir paris constitue une exception sur
laquelle on reviendra un peu plus tard
puisque c'est un corps de métier en
particulier la hausse des marchands de
l'eau qui administre la ville à partir
de 1260
auparavant elle a déjà la particularité
d'être la ville qui accumule le plus de
fonctions religieuses puisqu'elle est le
siège des déchets et comprend de
nombreux monastères économique grâce au
commerce et à la production artisanale
c'était déjà le cas à mon époque
universitaire dès le douzième siècle
avec l'installation d'une école près de
la cathédrale puis de l'université au
xiiie siècle et enfin politique parce
que le roi dès le 6e siècle paris était
la capitale de clovis men et résidez pas
et me gouverner pas elle est remplacée
par aix la chapelle sous les
carolingiens mais redevient importantes
à partir du 10e siècle est
principalement sous philippe auguste au
12e siècle il décide de transférer à
paris son trésor et ses archives
ce qui en fait sa capitale
administrative il était aussi construire
une enceinte en 1190 et à partir du
xiiie siècle les rois de france y
résident de plus en plus parce que c'est
joli
au 14ème siècle les services fiscaux s'y
installe aussi la présence du roi et de
sa cour ainsi que de plus en plus
d'officiers royaux stimule encore plus
l'économie de la ville bref c'est tout
bénef pour les parisiens en plus de
s'installer à paris les rois de france
cherche à reprendre le contrôle sur les
privilèges des autres villes lorsqu'il
rentre dans une ville
cérémonie veut que les bourgeois lui
remettre la charte communale afin qu ils
à leur ré accord dans l'ordre alors
qu'ils n'avaient absolument rien à voir
avec tout ça philippe auguste accorde
aussi des charges communales aux villes
qui sont sur le domaine royal à partir
du xvième siècle autonomie des villes
commencent à diminuer avec l'émergence
de l'absolutisme comme on l'a déjà un
peu mentionné en ville on trouve pas que
de la ville mais aussi des chants des
jardins des animaux etc
l'archéologie nous permet de retrouver
ces espaces inoccupés puisqu'on y trouve
de la terre noire une terre sur laquelle
rien n'a été bâti de la même manière
tu sais comment on appelle une mère qui
n'a jamais été occupé non mais ça n'a
pas vraiment de sens le noir au fur et à
mesure que les villes grossistes par
contre l'accès à de la nourriture
fraîche se fait de plus en plus
difficile et nécessite la mise en place
d'un circuit économique
déjà on fait sécher certains produits
pour les conserver plus longtemps comme
les fruits ou on les trempe dans du
vinaigre du miel ou encore une salle les
gens nous on importe du blé du vin de la
viande des poissons parfois de très loin
puisque venise importe du blé de
vulgaires et la france achète des
produits hongrois par exemple avec les
importations apparaissent des
appellations dès le xiiie siècle comme
les pâtes et de paris la moutarde de
dijon le maroilles de maroilles des
halles secret pour accueillir des
marchés qui sont encore libres au 10ème
siècle les autorités n'interviennent que
pour contrôler la marchandise vérifier
que le vin n'est pas coupé avec de l'eau
par exemple mais chaque métier a sa
propre juridiction et se gère tout seul
jusqu en 1183 du moins où philippe
auguste met en place les premières
réglementations de marché avant ça comme
je les dis chaque métier avait sa propre
juridiction
on appelait ce système les corporations
aussi appelé guilde confrérie ans et
c'est elle décidé dès droits et les
devoirs souvent strict des gens du
métier dans la ville est constitué aussi
une caisse commune au cas où quelqu'un
du métier tomberaient malades ou mouret
solidaires les compétences des gens de
ces corporations allait même plus loin
puisqu'il devait aussi assuré le gay de
la ville la lutte contre les incendies
ou l'entretien des remparts un artisan
était d'abord apprenti durant quelques
années
puis il pas ses compagnons et enfin il
pouvait devenir maître dans ce cas là
elle pouvait ouvrir sa propre boutique
et prendre à son tour des apprentis
l'existence de ces corporations permet
de connaître les métiers présents dans
les villes puisque en 1268
le roi 2009 charge etienne boileau de
lister toutes les corporations de paris
on constate alors qu'il existe près de
900 métier ayant chacun leur statut de
métier qui règlement de certaines choses
comme le travail des femmes d'artisans
par exemple elle exerçait souvent le
même métier que leur mari mais ne
pouvait pas devenir maître ou encore
prendre des apprentis parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas jugés assez capable
cependant beaucoup de statues de métier
emploie des termes mixte pour parler des
gens du métier comme celles et ceux et
ça fait plutôt plaisir en opposition à
ces groupes stricte émergent à partir du
12ème siècle système des compagnons ce
sont des ouvriers qui préfèrent rester
itinérant pour échapper à toutes ces
règles
ils sont plutôt clandestins alors ils se
réunissent dans des auberges et se
reconnaissent grâce à des signes
distinctifs
comment ils être souple
ma soupe est bon tous les artisans dont
je parlais peuvent vendre leurs produits
dans leurs boutiques mais aussi lors de
foires est l'une des plus réputées et
celle de provins elle appartient aux
comtes de champagne dans la région
réputée pour sa production agricole et
ses villes marchandes
à la différence d'un banal marchés les
foires attire des marchands qui viennent
de très loin comme d'italie ou de
flandre et qui vendent des produits qui
viennent d'encore plus loin des foires
de champagne c'est le rassemblement de
l'année dès le 11 ème siècle les
rassemblements même parce qu'il y en a
une en b et hull en automne elles durent
quarante six jours et on est trouvée
jusqu'à 40000 personnes leur essor est
permis par les comtes de champagne qui
sécurise les voix organise des convois
sur la sécurité des marchands elle
entraîne un formidable essor de cette
région à tel point que le denier
provinois la monnaie locale devient une
monnaie de référence dans toute l'europe
petit à petit des bâtiments spécialisés
secret comme des granges ou des maisons
de commerce que les marchands loué le
temps de la foire le commerce évolue
aussi puisqu'à partir des années 1950
les marchands ne voyage plus avec du
liquide mais avec des lettres de change
et donc les foires se double de centres
financiers dans lesquels on trouve des
changeurs qui sont là pour changer tout
en argent ces foires décline cependant
dans la deuxième moitié du xiiie siècle
à cause du développement des routes
terrestres à travers les alpes et aussi
du commerce fluvial qui permet à paris
de devenir plus importante que les
foires de provins toute façon j'étais
plutôt pro hydromel et pour terminer on
va s'intéresser aux habitants beaucoup
d'habitants des villes sont d'anciens
euro qui se regroupent souvent par
origine géographique
on retrouve cette origine dans leur nom
qui peut devenir par exemple le normand
lebreton etc
ils peuvent venir de loin ou des
villages alentour mais il reste toujours
moins honorable que les anciens et
partir vivre en ville n'efface pas non
plus les rumeurs qui pouvaient courir
sur les nouvelles vont vite on pense que
les étrangers représentent 20 à 30% de
la population des villes qu'ils soient
là pour s'installer ou de passage comme
des marchands des courtisans des
compagnons étudiants etc
selon les époques et selon les lieux les
dirigeants des villes encourage cette
immigration et l'insertion de ces
personnes en leur accordant leur
protection par exemple dans le but de
repeupler la ville après une épidémie ou
la décourage si la situation économique
est mauvaise dans certaines villes les
étrangers sont regroupés par quartier et
mis en marge
alors que d'autres villes comme
il refuse que les étrangers soient dans
des quartiers spécifiques pour faciliter
leur intégration en tout cas comme à
beaucoup d'époque on leur réserve plutôt
les métiers pénibles dont personne ne
veut et certains s'organisent en
confréries d'étrangers pour accueillir
les nouveaux venus et pratiquer leur
fête locale
on trouve aussi beaucoup de pauvres en
ville au moyen-âge cette expression ne
désigne pas seulement ceux qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent mais aussi les faibles
les malades les trop jeunes trop vieux
trop étranger etc mais souvent toutes
ces différences font qu'ils sont pauvres
au sens propre aussi selon les villes 70
à 80% de la population est trop pauvres
pour payer les impôts on appelle alors
ces personnes les niches il d'une
atteinte ni qui signifierait des gens
qu'ils sont rien mais comme on
s'intéresse peu à eux on manque de
sources à leur sujet et enfin il y avait
les bourgeois à la base ce terme désigne
juste les habitants du bourg
mais à partir du 12ème siècle il évolue
pour désigner les citadins les plus
privilégiés à partir du 14e siècle par
exemple les parisiens les plus notables
se désigne comme bourgeois de paris
il existe des rues alors non parce
qu'ils sont parmi les premiers à prendre
un nom de famille en plus du prénom et
il adopte même des armoiries ce groupe
représente environ 25% des parisiens et
parmi eux les 1% les plus riches payent
80 % des impôts
ce sont souvent des marchands liées au
commerce de luxe qui vendent un peu tout
mais aussi des rentiers qui vivent des
maisons qu'ils possèdent leur statut sa
compagne de pas mal de privilèges plutôt
sympathique et bénéficie de la
protection royale dans tout le royaume
puisque leur seigneur et juste le roi de
france ils sont exemptés du droit de
gîtes qui veut que le roi et sa cour
peuvent réquisitionner n'importe qu'elle
demeure et peuvent saisir les biens
parisiens de leurs débiteurs leur mode
de vie se rapproche de celui de la cour
dont il partage les loisirs mais ils ne
sont pas vraiment attiré par la noblesse
parce qu'ils ont déjà un statut pas trop
mal comme on vient de le voir
il reste aussi souvent entre eux en
famille parce que la coutume veut qu'un
enfant qui quitteraient le domicile
recevrez directement sa part de
l'héritage donc dans des familles
commerçantes où la fortune ne fait que
grimper
autant rester jusqu'au bout solidaires
on trouve certains de ces bourgeois à
des postes importants dans l'hôtel du
roi par exemple et ils prennent toujours
son parti lors des révoltes urbaines à
partir de 1170 c'est bon je pars et
obtiennent des fonctions encore plus
importante
louis 7 accorde à la corporation des
marchands d'eau le monopole du commerce
sur la seine entre les ponts de paris et
de menthe contre 50% des revenus
des amendes qu'ils ont le droit de
dresser à partir de là cette corporation
devient un peu toute puissante et un
marchand étrangers qui voudraient
commercer à paris doit s'associer avec
eux à partir de 1267 11 des marchands de
l'eau se transforme en municipalité ce
sont donc eux qui ont les fonctions
politiques tels que paver les rues lever
l'impôt entretenir les remparts assuré
le gay etc
tout comme les échevins qui dirigent les
grandes villes au détriment des
seigneurs les marchands de paris occupe
une place de plus en plus importante au
niveau politique que le roi leur délègue
bien volontiers l'épisode le plus long
de la chaîne je pense s'achève donc et
j'aurais pu parler encore de plein
d'autres choses comme des universités
mais je pense que ça mériterait plutôt
un épisode à part entière et avant de
partir je tiens aussi à remercier toutes
les personnes qui ont participé à la
campagne hull et qui nous ont permis de
rapporter beaucoup d'argent pour la
série time warp là je tourne le 29 avril
et nous sommes à 2758 euros ce qui est
très bien et n'hésitez pas à continuer
de partager parce que la campagne n'est
pas fini il reste seulement quelques
jours et j'ai mis un nouveau palier sur
le hull puisque on n'attendra pas les
4000 mais ce serait vraiment bien qu'on
puisse atteindre ce palier de 3000 qui
nous permettraient de conclure le budget
qui a été fait là il manque
80 euros pour ce budget là plus de
pouvoirs aussi payer notre graphiste et
avoir un compositeur pour la musique
donc voilà c'est les 3 dernières choses
qui serait bien qu'on est et pour le
reste on n'ira pas plus haut mais
n'hésitez pas donc continuer de partager
de données si vous voulez de commenter
voilà tout ça oui il fait donc ça et
comme ça ça nous permettra de faire une
belle série en plus de chroniques de
profs
youpi we need you est donc en attendant
la prochaine vidéo au revoir
[Musique]
armé que winston du yo yo yo demain je
vais tuer
tous les mecs
[Musique]
m
et
le haut
mais eux
oyo